se trata de una medida histórica en un
país que no ha modificado la edad legal
de consentimiento desde 1907 el viernes
Japón aprobó nuevas reformas que elevan
la edad de consentimiento de 13 a 16
años y cambiar la definición legal de
violación anteriormente la leyera
japonesa definía la violación como
relación sexual forzada Lo importante es
que ahora amplía esa definición a
relación sexual No consentida
si me preguntaran si los menores pueden
o no emitir juicios claros dudo que
puedan hacerlo hasta los 16 años Así que
creo que estoy a favor de esta ley
algunos sin embargo se mostraron
escépticos sobre si las reformas que
también penalizan el vallarismo traerían
algún cambio
no estoy segura pero me pregunto si el
vallerismo acabará incluso con una ley
que lo prohíba
los activistas que han estado
presionando durante años han acogido con
satisfacción la medida que alinea las
leyes de delitos sexuales de Japón con
las de otros países las múltiples
absoluciones por violación en 2019
desataron una campaña nacional contra la
violencia sexual bautizada como la
demostración de las Flores la nueva ley
también amplia de 10 a 15 años la
ventana legal para denunciar violaciones
pero aún queda trabajo por hacer ya que
la supervivientes de agresiones sexuales
en Japón a menudo dudan en denunciar los
ataques debido a la vergüenza y el
estigma